have you ever gotten up in a good mood
put on your absolute favorite outfit
went outside to have a fun day in the
sun and then ended up soaking wet caught
in a sudden rainstorm
yeah same
unfortunately we can't control the
weather weather changes from day to day
and from place to place so scientists
have to consider a lot of different
factors to understand it
weather can refer to humidity or amount
of water vapor in the air temperature
air pressure wind and of course
precipitation like rain or snow
when heat from the sun enters earth's
lower atmosphere it affects the
temperature and humidity of the air
as this national aeronautics and space
administration map shows air masses with
certain characteristics tend to form in
similar places there's many ways to
classify these air masses but to keep it
simple these blue blobs represent colder
air masses which tend to be closer to
the poles and the red blobs represent
warm air masses which are often found
near the equator where the sun's energy
is strongest
the qualities of an air mass may also
depend on where it forms air masses that
form over land tend to have less
humidity than those that form over an
ocean
air masses can even change
characteristics as they move
for example when a very cold and dry air
mass moves over the ocean it will likely
pick up warmth and moisture transforming
it into a slightly warmer and more humid
air mass
weather results from these air masses
moving from areas with high air pressure
to areas with low air pressure when this
happens a high or low pressure system
can form
a high pressure system has higher
pressure at its center than the areas
around it so air moves out from the
center high pressure systems typically
bring clear skies
a low pressure system has lower pressure
at its center than the areas around it
so air is sucked into the center of the
system
low pressure systems typically bring
more intense weather
why is this
well low pressure systems are often
associated with what we call fronts
a front is a boundary that forms when
air masses of different temperatures
collide near earth's surface
different types of fronts can form
depending on how those air masses meet
a warm front occurs when a warm air mass
moves in to replace a cold air mass
since warm air is less dense than cold
air it rises above the colder air
causing a lot of overcast skies moderate
rain or snow and warm temperatures
a cold front occurs when a cold air mass
moves in to replace a warm air mass
the dense cold air pushes the warmer air
mass upward causing larger clouds to
billow overhead and bring heavy rain or
thunderstorms strong winds and cool
temperatures with them
weather is so complex that it can be
difficult to predict what will happen
next
luckily scientists have developed
technologies that help model weather
patterns so we can all make more
informed choices about what to expect
when we go outside
to do that they set up tools like
satellites and doppler radar to observe
atmospheric conditions such as wind
speed temperature air pressure and
nearby geographic features
they can input the data they record into
computer models which can use that
information to predict future weather
have you ever seen a map like this used
in a weather forecast
this national oceanic and atmospheric
administration map uses data from a
doppler radar station that measured the
progression of a severe storm over the
northeastern united states the most
intense central parts of the storm are
shown in red with colors down the
rainbow representing progressively less
intense parts of the storm
as technology has advanced these weather
reports have gotten more accurate but
with so many factors to consider weather
is still only somewhat predictable
that's why you'll always hear
probabilistic weather predictions
providing a percentage that refers to
how confident the model is that the
prediction will happen
if your local weather forecast says
there's a 30 chance of rain it's less
likely but still possible that you're
going to get rain if it says there's a
90 chance of snow on another day you're
most likely going to get snow
even if weather predictions aren't
perfect it's amazing that scientists
figured out how to understand such a
complicated phenomenon without modern
tools and models it would be much more
difficult for us to plan ahead and be
prepared for possible weather hazards
next time you have a fancy day out
planned be sure to check the weather
forecast before you go if it says
there's a decent chance of rain don't
forget your umbrella